there's been a long running effort by
the big tech companies in Silicon Valley
to convince Americans that they need to
strap expensive devices to their faces
in the name of augmented reality the
idea is that instead of just looking at
the world and the people in the world
like a normal person you can instead
overlay information in real time over
everything you see because who wants to
look at the world right the world who
wants reality who wants the world and
like the Earth and all of the Splendor
of of of Nature and the universe who
wants any yeah we need no we need uh we
need to we need to Spruce it up a little
bit so you can look at like sports
scores while you're outside on the beach
you can answer text messages without
without pulling out your phone no matter
where you go you can have an app right
in front of your face floating in front
of you now most people spend 10 hours a
day looking at their phones already but
big Tech says we need to pump those
numbers up we need we need to make sure
that we are using their products
literally every waking moment of the day
those very few hours of autonomy and
independent thought and actual
engagement with the physical world um
that that that most people get these
days even that has to be claimed by our
Silicon Valley o overlords they see that
as a problem the fact that we still have
any of that the fact that we have two
hours a day when we're not looking at
screens that's like they're saying we
got to get those two hours we can't let
them have the two hours they want it all
all of it that's the idea inside the
bowels of Silicon Valley marketing
departments you can tell that they've
they've never been totally sure about
this pitch and how to go about they
understand how unnatural all of this
sounds so they've always done their best
to paper over kind of the nerd Factor
the loser Factor uh of needing to have
this screen in your face at all times in
order to make augmented reality seem
cool so 12 years ago for example Google
unveiled its first big augmented reality
product called the Google Glass but the
centerpiece of their demo was not some
overweight guy secretly scrolling
through the internet as he sat alone on
his sofa instead Google decided to
portray Google Glass as the product of
choice for skydivers and Daredevils who
for some reason want to broadcast
extremely lowquality video of their
jumps over the Internet so here's um a
few Snippets of the demo which which we
can conclusively say 12 years later is a
textbook example of trying way too hard
here it is
watch that looks like the view down it
looks like long way down yeah you can
turn it turn it sideways oh yeah there's
the ball part good Stu here yep yeah MOS
Center I got a visual on you you know
it's um it's pretty exciting hopefully
they they
landed all right and they're coming
in first one's coming
in all
[Applause]
right and you know there's only one good
way way down the side of a
building have
fun it's pretty high up there if you
haven't been up there before don't try
this at home kids these are trained
professionals all right now we got to
get down
there want to unplug me all right here
they going oh wait wait wait that one
wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa who no no no
we're on the third
okay oh you can picture the marketing
meeting that to this they knew they had
a weird kind of nerdy product they knew
that nobody wanted to wear this outside
it's an aesthetic nightmare so they
decided to uh pay some people to jump
out of an airplane while they're wearing
Google Glass and then they repel down
the building like they're in a mission
impossible movie and they race around
with it on bikes and they they do
everything possible to make you forget
about the actual product which does
precisely one thing during this whole
demonstration it streams an extremely
blown out lowquality video over the
Internet it does what a $20 webcam would
do basically needless to say Google
Glass was a failure Google shut down the
entire product line shortly afterwards
but big Tech was not deterred a company
called Oculus started releasing their
own headsets before they were bought by
meta and these headsets were not
designed simply for augmented reality
but also for virtual reality this means
that you put VR goggles on your face
they completely then replace your normal
vision they they don't simply complement
what you see in the real world although
they they're all capable of doing that
as well in many cases these VR goggles
can completely replace uh the physical
world that you're looking at
now to Market these VR headsets meta
went exactly the opposite direction of
Google instead of trying to desperately
appear cool meta decided to be as
aggressively weird and creepy as they
could possibly be it was a bold
marketing strategy we must say to give
you an example of what it looked like
here's how meta announced one of their
exciting new VR software updates a
little over a year ago the point of this
new update was to announce that within
the metaverse which is the company's VR
Universe people will soon be able to see
each other uh with legs so pretty soon
they'll have legs that's the big update
they'll no longer be floating heads with
no limbs and to announce this
breakthrough VR Mark Zuckerberg struts
out with his VR legs while his adoring
audience still legless applauds
enthusiastically and tosses confetti in
the air it's a it's like a real life
Black Mirror episode here it is watch
there's one more feature coming soon
that's probably the most requested
feature on our road map
legs
legs I know you have been waiting for
this I think everyone has been waiting
for this but seriously the legs are hard
which is why other virtual reality
systems don't have them either and the
perceptual science behind this is
actually quite interesting and we
discovered early on so you see the
little people are Overjoyed that the
founder of their VR world has legs now
maybe one day they too will have VR legs
now the metaverse needless to say was an
unconditional failure when it was
announced City valued the metaverse at
trillion doll that's how much value they
said it could bring to the world 13
trillion but after it launched nobody
used it the most popular platform in the
metaverse had just 38 active users every
day Horizon worlds which was supposedly
the killer app for the metaverse
reportedly made just
$470 that's $470 and0 total like you
could make more money if you filmed
yourself lighting random objects on fire
and uploaded it to YouTube and meta
spent like $40 billion on this in fact
they could have lit the $40 billion on
fire and put that on YouTube and and
they would have made a lot more than 47
470 bucks back in add dollars keeping
windshields clean is always a pain
especially in the winter that's why I'm
so grateful to have windshield wow
windshield wow is an Innovative
windshield cleaning device that uses two
magnetic cleaning paddles one on the
outside one on the inside of your car to
clean both sides of your windshield all
from the outside being able to clean
both the front and the inside of your
window at the same time is a GameChanger
wish I had one of these years ago
seriously all you got to do is just push
around the outside paddle and the inside
follows automatically leaving your
windshield squeaky clean we had a pretty
big snowstorm here in Nashville and with
all the dirt and salt piled up on the
road washer fluid just couldn't get the
job done luckily I had a windshield wow
uh in my trunk to save the day that's
what's awesome about windshield wow it's
so easy to throw these in the back of
your car so you can always have a clean
clean windshield the windshield wow
applies firm cleaning pressure it's
super thin to get into those tight
dashboard areas so what are you waiting
for go to windshield wow.com use promo
code Walsh a check out for a special
discount that's windshield wow.com and
use code Walsh now as I say this I know
there are some people who um you know
say that well these are just early
iterations of a technology that
eventually is going to become ubiquitous
that's certainly what Silicon Valley
thinks they're not stopping with these
products they're continuing to pour
money into it and that's why Apple has
just released something called the Apple
Vision Pro The Vision Pro is essentially
a slightly more advanced version of
meta's VR headsets so it's a giant hunk
of metal and plastic that you you put on
your face it tracks your hands allows
you to interact with virtual apps so you
may have seen videos of people
influencers using this thing in public
and here's what that looks like
watch
okay good so if you want to look like a
schizophrenic on the subway you wear one
of those as if there aren't enough
schizophrenics on the subway already
watching these clips it's it's not hard
to imagine that very soon we'll be
reading reports about Apple Vision Pro
uh Vision Pros being ripped off of
people's faces while they type away at
the invisible keyboard in the sky these
things cost $3500 by the way it's a
$3,500 piece of equipment you are
wearing on your face on the subway
way it it and and you're doing it in a
way where you have reduced peripheral
vision and much less situational
awareness it's hard to imagine a dumber
idea than wearing one of these things
outside in an urban environment but
people are doing it anyway because they
have no regard for their personal safety
that's how committed they are to the
future of spatial Computing and
augmented reality but of course there's
something deeply strange uh about it
which is why you know everyone's filming
these clips covering your face in public
is not normal no matter how many times
they told us to wear masks you know
during Co it never became normal seeing
people's faces is the main way you
understand them and recognize them and
interact with them people will just
never get used to this because it flies
in the face of just our basic human
psychology that certainly explains the
reaction to one popular YouTube
personality who showed off the Vision
Pro recently in New York City and he put
the video up and it's basically just
walking around people are looking at him
like he's a freak because well he looked
incredibly stupid St walking around with
the giant clunky nerd goggles on his
face this is what you get for spending
$3,500 to attach a big Tech Gadget
directly to your face you get the
confused stares of strangers that's
assuming they don't just take the thing
off your face and run away and pawn it
somewhere which is what's going to end
up happening now if it sounds like I'm
mocking the idea that this technology
will ever will ever catch on or that I'm
saying that the whole project is doomed
to fail and big Tech will have to
eventually give up that's not what I'm
saying in fact I think the opposite
outcome is more likely Silicon Valley
will continue to pump trillions of
dollars into this technology and and
then they'll make it smaller and more
affordable they'll do everything they
can to make augmented reality the next
big thing that strips away whatever is
left of our privacy and autonomy as
human beings smartphones smart watches
other smart devices they were the first
major step and um you know now people
don't don't leave their computers behind
anywhere like everywhere they go They're
tracked their purchases are tracked
their location is tracked the social
media use is tracked and when the time
comes that everybody's wearing VR and
augmented reality headsets then
everything they see in real life will be
tracked
to and that's that's that's one absolute
inevitability here like you wear one of
these things and you are giving big Tech
immediate access to everything you do
everywhere you go and everything you
see which means and that's why like why
do you that that's the story here that
they've spent a big Tech spent a lot of
money on this billions and billions it's
it it hasn't worked yet they're they
keep on trying for a decade now they've
been trying why are they so desperate to
make this
work because of the absolute power and
control it gives them over the people
who buy this
stuff it means that you know you are
destroying not only your own privacy but
also the privacy of everybody that you
look at and Inter interact with because
they will automatically be on camera
through your nerd goggles but but worse
than all that worse than the final death
of whatever is left of our privacy worse
is the fact that the nerd goggles set up
a filter between you and the real world
you are allowing Apple to provide the
literal lens by which you see and access
the world around you you we already have
a a major problem of big Tech through
its
algorithms um determining and large part
how we perceive the outside world and
what we know about the outside world so
that already there are they are already
able to shape that through their
algorithms but the nerd goggles will be
the final step they'll put the last nail
on the coffin of our independent
perception of the
world should that happen it'll be
another giant probably irreversible step
towards a
dehumanizing and basically unlivable
dystopia people become more distant
disconnected more Tech dependent than
they've already are therefore more
depressed and anxious and joy list than
they already are there'll be nowhere
anyone can hide from the allseeing eye
of Silicon Valley
oligarchs and that's why they're so
obsessed with getting this technology
off the ground that's why they've spent
billions and billions of billions of
dollars to make their dark dystopian
dream a reality and they'll spend
billions more until it
happens and that's why the Apple Vision
Pro and all other devices that want to
block out your surroundings and make you
exist in some artificial big Tech
constructed world
are today cancelled thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
to my full podcast on the go you can
check out the Matt wall show on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcast